jean christophe lagarde président de
l'udps et y député de la 5e
circonscription de seine-saint-denis
dont on vient de voir la réaction sur
twitter bonsoir jean christophe lagarde
merci d'être avec nous vous faites donc
partie de ceux qui souhaitaient un délai
à vous parler de surdité de la part du
gouvernement fin de non recevoir de
l'exécutif votre réaction ce soir déçu
oui déçu parce que regarder le
gouvernement qui nous a dit il nous faut
quinze jours que le comprend pour
pouvoir élaborer une stratégie de
confinement et nous il faudrait qu'on
ait 15 minutes pour décider si on prouve
que c'est bien ou pas alors que se pose
des dizaines de questions sur le retour
alcool qu elle soit maternelle qu'elle
soit élémentaires collèges ou lycées sur
la façon dont on peut pratiquer dans les
transports sur la façon dont on peut
travailler dans tel ou tel corps de
métier qui doit être priorisés mais
avant tout davantage encore sur la
territorialisation de déconfinement
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je parle la
région brandt est l'algérie de france
qui sont les deux régions les plus
touchées de france sont huit à neuf fois
plus touchés que la bretagne que la
région centre val de loire que la
nouvelle aquitaine
on pourrait d'ores et déjà d'ailleurs
sans doute libéré une partie du
territoire français le virus n'a
quasiment pas si la pub et où les dbz
d'urgence entre guillemets enfin les
services d'urgence dans les hôpitaux
sont en état de réagir s'il y avait un
problème alors que en ile-de-france dans
les autres france les personnels sont
épuisés lice les médicaments
anesthésiants ne sont plus là les
équipements doivent être constituées en
cas de deuxième bague
donc il ya tellement de choses dont nous
devrions de peur que deux les 24 heures
au début tu es pour pouvoir en débattre
entre eux parce qu'il faut observer une
chose demain nous serons 75 dans
l'assemblée nationale et il 577 députés
c'est à dire qu'il ya 500 de députés qui
ne seront pas là qu'ils ne peuvent pas
voter ou débattre et échanger entre eux
ont demandé 24 heures simplement pour
pouvoir en discuter entre nous comme les
français vont le faire comme le
gouvernement va le faire avec tout le
monde et c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment
que on est revenu à l'autoritarisme du
début du quinquennat d'avant les gilets
jaunes
ensemble on finit par vouloir nous faire
marcher au sein de canon moi j'ai pas de
souci à prendre position et accepter mes
responsabilités à condition que nos
questions nous forger une idée dignement
sa garde tout de même semaine pardonnez
moi cette semaine de confinement pour
des français qui pour certains
commencent voilà à trouver le temps long
souhaite pour certains retourner au
travail
on a vu le nombre de chômeurs qui
augmente vous le dites vous-même ya
tellement de sujets abordés il ya un
gouvernement qui a été élu voilà
pourquoi ne pas faire confiance aux
simplement au gouvernement pour prendre
les décisions vous pose volontairement
la question d'abord il ya de réponse à
votre question la première réponse c'est
que si on décide et on l'a fait en 48
heures l'ensemble des groupes politiques
du parlement ont donné il ya six
semaines les pleins pouvoirs au
gouvernement pour gérer la crise parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire des lois la
vitesse où le virus se propage et six
semaines après si on a le sentiment
c'était un grand succès si on a le
sentiment qu'on nous a pas raconter des
bobards sur les masques que on a des
problèmes sur les thèses qui sont
toujours pas là que finalement la france
s'en sort mieux que d'autres pays
quand on observe l'allemagne la suède où
d'autres alors en ce moment là oui on
supprime le parlement et puis on n'a
qu'à dire que le gouvernement est le
seul à gérer la crise dans ces cas là
pourquoi un débat pourquoi un vote
la réalité c'est que il fallait
construire ceci et je vais même vous
dire j'ai la conviction qu'il n'y aura
de succès dans le déconfinement promener
si c'est à dire qu'on arrive à reprendre
une vie à peu près normale
un peu modifié naturellement en
contrôlant la circulation du ciel mirus
qu'à une condition qu'il y ait la
confiance des français
or les français n'ont pas confiance
parce qu'ils ont vu qu'on l'a raconté
des mensonges de les masquer et si le
gouvernement passe en force comme
malheureusement parfois la majorité le
dit habitué sans donner le temps de la
compréhension sans donner le temps de
comprendre de l'aja restriction sans
donner le temps de la correction des
mesures qui seront données 24 heures
c'était pas grand chose
eh bien les français ne remettront pas
leurs enfants à l'école ils n'y vont pas
travailler
il prend pas
transport s'ils ont le sentiment qu'on
leur raconte à nouveau des histoires et
c'est ça ce qui me rend malheureux c'est
que pour des raisons de réflexes
politiques on évite d'arriver à
construire ensemble ce faisant nous
avons besoin moi je dis pas du tout et
vous dites avec confinement les gens en
ont marre mais moi aussi j'en ai marre
tout le monde en a marre on sait bien
qu'il faudra accorder confient les très
franchement le 11 mai ou le 30 septembre
on aura le même problème parce que le
virus continuera à circuler mais la
question c'est de prendre la discussion
la réflexion nécessaire pour qu'on ne
commettent pas d'erreurs
est ce qu'on est sûr que quand on nous a
dit il ya deux mois on ferme les écoles
d'abord parce que c'est là qu'il ya le
plus grand risque de propagation de
virus puisque les enfants peuvent porter
le transmettre sans être malade
on le voit pas mais la première chose
qu'on est con financer les écoles on est
sûr que ça marche
est ce qu'on pense franchement que les
écoles maternelles on va arriver où les
crèches arriver à faire respecter la
distanciation sociale les gestes
barrière alors c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que les médecins depuis son revenu un
petit peu sur les propos initiaux
concernant justement ces enfants super
propagateurs de virus peut-être voilà
c'est un début d'explication
vous souhaitiez jean christophe lagarde
également un vote dissocier sur l'appli
qu'ovide et sur le déconfinement pour
quelles raisons c'était important pour
vous parce que ce sont deux sujets de
nature différente
l'abricot ville c'est un des éléments à
des outils dans la boîte à outils du
comédien âge du nez confinement et la
stratégie de confinement
la question qui se pose est d'ailleurs
il ya quinze jours en semaine quand on a
demandé à la fois seconde séparée et que
je souhaiterais que les gouvernements là
non plus n'acceptera pas c'était est ce
qu'il ya un problème sur les libertés
publiques moi je dis aux français
après examen après audition de ministre
après avoir regardé ce qu'ils font il
n'y a pas de problème sur les libertés
publiques donc vous pourrez sans risque
téléchargez l'application quand elle
viendra des skoda en revanche un tj qui
confie quand on passe la fête la
bretagne à l'ayguade que service de le
pape en plus
mulhouse c'est la parole non alors
pourquoi on peut mettre tout le monde
sur la même foi alors que les situations
sont différentes indique complètement
intelligents et responsables progressive
comme on le dit c'est de s'adapter à
trois choses 1 est-ce que des russes a
beaucoup circulé dans la région ou dans
le territoire en question
2 est ce qui reste des capacités de
soins notamment dans les services de
réanimation où est-ce qu'ils sont à bout
et il faut leur laisser le temps de
reconstituer leurs forces
3 est ce que les masques de protection
sont arrivés et dans les territoires et
ben non parce que le gouvernement nous a
dit il faut pas de masque pourquoi parce
qu'elle n'avait pas c'est comme si les
français n'avaient pas été capables de
comprendre n'auraient pas été capables
de comprendre que comme on n'avait pas
assez de masques il fallait les réserver
aux soignants parce que si les soignants
moeurs et le personnes pour le soigner
si on ne vais pas raconter des bobards
ya deux mois c'était plus simple
aujourd'hui de créer la confiance est là
il ya des collectivités locales qui
achètent des vastes l'état achète des
masses pour les soignants pas pour les
français
contrairement aux autres et vivre
président de la république et il ya les
collectivités locales qui achètent des
masques simplement faut le temps de les
produire faut le temps qu'ils arrivent
donc je suis convaincue qu' il ya des
territoires qui sans doute pourrait être
d confiné dès demain parce que le virus
il peut circuler que leur état
hospitalier est en bonne situation de
faire face et parce qu'ils ont peut-être
fonctionne mal et puis il ya des
endroits où ça sera pas possible 11 mai
donc différer cette affaire hélas non on
décide d'en haut une date du 11 mai
d'hondt accessoirement le conseil
scientifique n'a jamais dit qu'elle
était bonne ou pas parce qu'il n'a pas
été consulté et on va donner on fait
partout la même chose
moi je crains que des compliments sur un
échec s'il n'ya pas confiance et si on
continue dans l'uniformité
merci à vous jean christophe lagarde
avoir été en direct sur rt france